IAN LAKE: For many, how
you use and navigate
your app can be classified
in one of two ways,
either browsing through
content, or by directed search
for specific content.
If your app isn't delivering a
good in-app search experience,
you're only serving
part of your user base.
Hi, I'm Ian Lake, and
I want to show you
what goes into building a great
in-app search experience using
SearchView, to help your
users get to exactly what they
want as easily as possible.
The basic building blocks
of a good search experience
start with perhaps the
hardest one, good content.
We're talking about searching
using a single query string.
But how that maps
onto your data--
be it a list of users or a
full text search of posts--
and how you store that
data is all in your hands.
Well, it may be helpful to
have a special Full Text
Search, or FTS, Table
locally on the device,
if your data set is small enough
and query speed is critical.
For now, let's focus on
the search process itself.
With search being such a
core navigation pattern,
it makes sense to standardize
on a single pattern
for providing search.
For Android, that involves
an aptly-named SearchView.
Usually, the SearchView is seen
as an action in the main app
bar, or an appropriate toolbar.
By tapping on the
SearchView icon,
the SearchView expands
inline, allowing users
to immediately search.
Through AppCompat, part of
the Android Support Library,
SearchView is available on all
Android 2.1 and higher devices.
Adding a SearchView
to your app bar
involves just adding another
item to the menu you inflate.
Besides the more
obvious title and icon,
you'll note the showAsAction
contains collapseActionView.
This is what tells the menu that
this item should be collapsed
by default, but can be expanded
into the full actionViewClass
that's defined.
We also need ifRoom-- or
alternatively, always--
for showAsAction.
Without this, our icon will
only appear in the overflow menu
and we won't be able to expand
it into the full SearchView.
Not what we want.
With just this addition,
we get a nice search icon
that expands into
the SearchView,
but the search doesn't really
go anywhere or do anything.
We can get a reference to
it when we inflate our menu,
but where do we go from there?
Firstly, there's
full manual mode,
using setOnQueryTextListener.
Here, you'll get a callback for
when the search text changes
and when the user submits
their search, giving you
full control over exactly
what happens when.
You can take advantage of a lot
more when you instead provide
a searchable configuration.
This is an XML
file, specifically
for all the various
options relating to search.
So many options that we have
a full documentation page just
on all the various options,
all nine pages of the detailed
explanations.
Thankfully, it can also
be super short and easy.
Just a label--
which would usually
be your app name-- and a hint
in the form of search posts
or search your app name.
Guess what it takes to add
voice search to your SearchView?
Just a single additional line to
your searchable configuration.
That's a pretty powerful line,
but remember that voice search
directly submits what is said.
There's no opportunity to
change things before submitting,
so make sure your
searches lend themselves
to voice before enabling it.
Then you'll associate that
searchable configuration
with an activity.
This is the activity
you want to go to when
the user submits a query.
You'll note we use
singleTop launch mode.
This is important if
you have a SearchView
on your searchable activity--
say, to do a second search.
And this launch mode prevents
a potential giant back
stack of search result screens.
Hooking up your SearchView
to a searchable configuration
uses SearchManager,
the system service
which parses that
metadata element you've
added to one of your
activities and creates
a searchable info you can
pass to your SearchView.
This launches our
searchable activity.
But to extract the actual search
text, we look for action search
and then extract the query
from the intent's extra.
You call this from
onCreate, and if you
are using that
singleTop launch mode,
call it from
onNewIntent, as well.
So you have a
great-looking SearchView
that directly searches to
the activity of our choice.
What we haven't talked about yet
are recent query suggestions,
or custom suggestions,
which make
things even easier for users
to find what they want.
Check out the developer
site for more information.
I can't wait to see
what awesome experiences
you come up with using
in-app search on your quest
to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]